vanessa brown nike opt not to renew
nearly 20 or long-term
long partnership over different
differences this is a fox business story
vanessa brown and kobe bryant's estate
decided not to extend their partnership
with nike which expired earlier this
month due to several differences between
the two sides
sources told espn that bryant and the
state were frustrated with the limited
availability of
brian's products and more significantly
that nike presented them with an offer
that was not in line with the
expectations of a lifetime deal similar
to those of michael jordan of
lebron james bryant originally signed
with nike in 03 the estate is now free
to negotiate a deal with new
brands what do you think about that
interesting
i thought it was the other way around i
thought nike didn't want to continue it
anymore
well they were not happy about the offer
so vanessa and the estate said we're not
interested
so nike made an offer but it wasn't the
rich offer of a jordan over lebron james
and they kind of
turned away well i think what's pretty
clear uh if you read anything about this
story is that
kobe rest in power um legend
uh is that he wanted to leave nike and
start his own mamba brand
much like the air jordan whether that's
under the nike umbrella
or or not but kobe look i think as
amazing as a basketball player as he was
and he'll go down as
top five top ten ever clearly right i
think
mj is number one kobe
will you know kareem russell whatever
wherever you want to put them
he's certainly in the top five shack top
ten
i think he would have been equally if
not better businessman than an athlete
and the run rate would have been triple
that what his
nba career was because by the time he
retired he was in his early 40s
and uh he had played for 20 years and i
think he would have had another 40 years
plus
of being a a businessman a role model
a dad a girl dad old i would i actually
would have respected his business
acumen more than his basketball acumen
because i think he would have changed
the world
business-wise and given an example um so
back to this
um i think he had uh a set of beliefs
that he wanted to
to abide by i think obviously vanessa
and the family knew about it
and i think you know don't be shocked if
a mamba brand comes out that's all i'm
saying
and you know i'm pat i'm sure you have a
perspective of a very unique perspective
on kobe because you're the only person
at the table that actually sat with him
for
hours on end and learn about his
perspective and his values and his
principles
but something that they talked about
here is a lifetime deal
but what happens when you're no longer
alive how do you bet on the athlete or
put me on behind the app
that's no longer alive yeah that's kind
of what i was talking to pat yesterday i
mean he's
you know unfortunately he's he's not
with us anymore so how do you you know
how do you continue you know
jordan is still thinking he does he did
his commercials even after he was out of
the nba
you know he's he's still uh you know he
did but the last dance which brought him
you know he michael jordan is very much
alive with the older generation our
generation but the newer generation
they're like they're chris
uh they're uh uh
chris was for the golden state warriors
christopher steph curry they're stephen
guys they're lebron james i don't know
basketball they're they're uh well i'm
just saying there's the newer generation
that they're those are they
think steph curry is the best thing ever
right right
which is true but i think the last dance
you know solidified his
right jordan his legacy he almost really
like people relived jordan again through
which was much needed which by the way
something that's kobe and fortune is not
going to be able to do
you know 20 30 years from now after he's
done with the league he's not going to
be able to relive through a last dance
series so uh yeah i mean i you know with
nike i i can understand both sides of it
he's not here anymore to push that and
vanessa's not going to push you she's
not the driver
no that's true what's your perspective
on this story but also just bigger
business acumen yeah so i mean the real
question you got to ask is the following
there's no way in the world vanessa
bryant with all the advisors she has
around her that are dying
you know like full-on kobe fans are
going to steer her in the wrong
direction right
and there's no way you're breaking a
deal with nike without having an
alternative you're just not going to do
it there's
no way in the world remember when
parlor fired the ceo the board did
and they fired the founder and we had a
meeting about five six months ago and i
said
if the board hires a ceo that gets
parlor back on the app
guess what the board gets credit for
bringing a better ceo and guess what
guess what happened apple is now
allowing parlor to get back
on the board get back on that and back
onto aws and
yes which means that credit goes to
credit goes to the board for firing
the uh founder and ceo parlor respect
there to the founder being fired okay
to the board so in this situation
we're sitting here listening to this
vanessa bryant and her group may be
sitting there saying nike just
lost big time
so you know we learned worldwide how
much
kobe was loved let's just face it we
learned how much kobe was loved you know
you you realize how much you're loved
unfortunately you will never find out
how much you're loved until
you're you're dead the only people that
are going to know how much you're loved
is the day you die how many people show
up to your funeral
and how stories start showing up that
nobody knew about
okay because those stories don't show up
until a person dies and start telling
these stories right a lot of them right
yeah
kobe died what happened everybody
stopped and everybody started telling
stories about kobe okay
um kobe started off with adidas if i'm
not mistaken when he first came into the
league
it wasn't nike i owned i think kobe had
an adidas shoe yep
i owned it today kobe's got what you got
today competition is to nike is who
under armour yeah you got uh
uh you got adidas where the hell is
reebok these days reebok is not going to
be the one that's going to play
play ball here but you got adidas and
you got
under armour okay and under armour is by
who today
under armour is they got the wayne
johnson they got a lot of guys if you
look at who under armour's got
and under armour's shoes today they're
actually good shoes i like under armour
shoes today not 20 not 10 years ago
not five years ago i wear under armour
shoes today i also wear nike but i wear
under armour shoes today is it likely
that someone's gonna pick this deal up
i think so why because that you know the
saying goes legends never
kobe is a hero he's a legend he's in a
league of his own i think somebody's out
there
already waiting to pick up this contract
that's willing to pay the massive
lifetime contract of
and a lifetime contract in this sense
could be a 50-year contract a 30-year
contract 100-year contract a 20-year
contract
because kobe is going to be relevant for
a very very long time to come he's not
going to be going away
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you